Social demographic profile
Mostly
We see this at the forefront of surveys
That we read
But why is it important to take it
Although there are similarities with our respondents
We recognize that
There is still a difference in our respondents
Based on what sub group they belong to
Let's see
We have a survey on political involvement of Cavitenos
During the 2022 elections
For sure there is a difference in gene views
z cavitenos
Millennial cavitenyos and jen x
Cavitenyos
In their being politically involved
During the elections
Generation
Educational Attainment
Gender and social economic status
Oursome examples of social demographic profiles
Apart from
We better recognize the make up of our sample
The social demography profile goes deeper
Let's analyze
In research
Stay curious researchmate